Tyrannybook.
Social media is a powerful tool...
...and we believe it can also be used for more relevant things.
That is why Amnesty International, Portugal created Tyrannybook.
Here, instead of watching your friends, you can watch your enemies.
But who are the enemies?
Every world leader who has no respect for human rights.
We can still prove with our own intelligence information that...
...he is guilty, sufficiently guilty to be able to be detained.
Here, their acts are updated as they happen.
You can watch as many tyrants as you want.
Become an ally with others who watch these tyrants.
Exchange information, links, pictures, videos...
"Nkomo has always denied that he controls dissidents."
...and find out how to help.
You can also invite friends from other social networks to join in.
After all, the more people we have watching, the more these dictators...
...will realize that their evil acts are not going unnoticed.
Tyrannybook.
Join. Fight. Change.